[Música]
porque es que ahí tensión política en
torno a los Juegos Olímpicos de Invierno
que se van a realizar en Beijing el año
que viene el gobierno de China entonces
amenaza con represalias Australia Reino
Unido y también Canadá han anunciado que
se unen al boicot diplomático iniciado
por Estados Unidos por lo que consideran
violaciones de derechos humanos
perpetradas por las autoridades chinas y
es que China ya reacciono como ya lo
hicimos una mente tras este anuncio
demás países de sumarse así al boicot
estadounidense según el portavoz de
Exteriores del gobierno chino el deporte
no tiene nada que ver con la política y
advirtió que quiénes se han unido a lo
que calificó como un error van a tener
que pagar este precio el boicot a estos
Juegos Olímpicos entonces de invierno
anunciados por algunos países se da como
respuesta a esta violación derechos
humanos en China y para ello nos
acompaña María Baeza ya es portavoz de
Amnistía Internacional en España gracias
María por estar con nosotros en directo
América de francés de 4 le pregunto cuál
es la situación de los derechos humanos
en China la verdad la comunidad
comunidad internacional tiene puesto el
derecho y si se justifica entonces este
boicot diplomático que varios países han
decidido hacer
la situación de los derechos humanos en
China es bastante lamentable y lo que ha
desencadenado esta última reacción es la
situación que viene viviendo la hernia y
Hugo y otras señas de religión musulmana
que habitan principalmente la región
autónoma de Xinjiang y que están
sufriendo un control tremendo en su vida
diaria con una vigilancia extensiva en
la región y donde cualquier persona
digamos
[Música]
pero donde todos los testimonios apuntan
a un Indochine amiento para cambiar los
planteamientos culturales la práctica en
las creencias y dónde se practican los
malos tratos y la tortura María también
tiene algo que ver esta situación con el
caso de la tenista profesional China
pensáis que recordemos que la comunidad
internacional la W e incluso suspendió
ya todos los torneos en el territorio
chino porque no se sabe muy bien del
paradero de pensar también pues el
Comité Olímpico Internacional e hizo una
videoconferencia con ella se comprometió
al año que viene a verla personalmente
pero todavía no es claro dónde está la
tenista qué pasa con ellas porque en las
apariciones públicas dile algo que ver
también con este caso mediático de
pienso ahí
pues es posible sino directamente lo de
los Juegos Olímpicos efectivamente está
bien otro reacción pero yo creo que es
un caso más que se suma y el caso de la
tenéis pero es una situación habitual en
China entre las personas que reclaman
sus derechos humanos o defienden otros
desapariciones de estas personas
que durante un tiempo no se sabe nada de
ellos y luego en ocasiones aparecen con
pensando que
bien habían actuado mal o bien que no
hay nada que están estupendamente que
están en libertad que pueden hacer una
vida normal pero
la prueba de su vida normal no existen
puesto que no se puede tener acceso a
libre a estas personas luego
no tenemos ninguna prueba de que ella
esté en la situación normal y no haya
sido forzada a hacer la declaración es
que es que María es también muy caso del
fundador de Alibaba qué es apareció por
prácticamente un año si no fue más o fue
un año y luego apareció que nada tiene
que ver que no pasa nada que no pasa
nada que
está mal
cualquier denuncia de unas acciones de
gobierno o de la actividad de una
persona de gobierno
puede ser interpretada o puede ser
juzgada como
un atentado contra la seguridad del
Estado y esto sufre
procesos y penas especiales es decir no
está sometida a las garantías judiciales
de cualquier otra persona que es
detenida sino que en China para estos
casos existe legalmente la autorización
de tener a la persona en lugar secreto
hasta seis meses luego las cosas van más
allá aparte de que durante seis meses
muy larga sin que sepamos nada de la
persona de hecho estamos motivo de los
Juegos Olímpicos lo que se ha planteado
China amnistía es trabajar por una serie
de casos que están en la cárcel
señal alguna manera en China y digamos
le echa tierra o no ve por el momento
acatar recordemos que también en la
construcción de los estadios del Mundial
de Qatar ha muerto muchísimas personas
también se dice que se practica la
esclavitud moderna ahí en ese territorio
y también últimamente se dio a conocer
que el comité organizador de este
Mundial de Fútbol de Qatar vídeo pues
pide Alaska las personas de la comunidad
LGBT y que no den muestras de afecto en
público porque eso puede caer mal en la
sociedad de ese país porque China y no
Catar
bueno
una cosa yo respondo de amnistía no de
lo que hacen los gobiernos de hecho
lleva desarrollando una campaña para
visibilizar las violaciones de derechos
humanos
[Música]